Here's,
I love this cartoon,
this is from a underground comic for,
for people who smoke way too much
marijuana and it's called a.
These people are the fabulous furry
freak brothers and they were created by
Gilbert Shelton who was one of the first
underground cartoonists and one of the
least pathological ones with the best
sense of humor and he writes these
stories about these stupid hippies,
three of them,
the fabulous furry freak brothers.
You see two of them there and all they
do is smoke pot and avoid responsibility
and and run away from the police and it,
but,
but it's a nice satire and so and they
have this cat and the fat one fat Freddy
has the cat and they're too lazy to even
give her the cat in name.
So it's fat Freddy's cat and it has its
own adventure is mostly with like an
army of cockroaches that that lives
inside.
They're like horrible slummy hell hole
of living place.
And so anyways,
it's quite comical.
And so the,
the hippies have stumbled across a small
fortune and stoned out of their minds on
cocaine.
They go out to set up utopia in the
countryside.
They buy this terrible piece of
property,
but they're so diluted that they think
it's like a mansion and they bring their
cat and I don't know if you've ever had
a cat,
but cats don't like to move.
It really bugs them and so they're not
comfortable when you bring them to a new
place.
They're like the rat that's been taken
out of its comfortable cage and put it
into a new cage and the cat,
you put a cat in a new room and it
depending on the cat obviously,
but generally they'll retreat into a
corner and be and meow pityingly and be
very unhappy for quite a substantial
amount of time.
And so the cartoonist actually map this
out quite nicely.
So the hippie takes the cat out of the
box and says our new home,
it's,
they're out in the forest.
This is the never been cat.
It's never been in the forest.
It doesn't know what the hell is up in
the forest.
And the cat's looking rather dubiously
and things.
So this is the country and then it's put
on the ground and it starts to slink as
he says,
slink,
slink out into the forest.
And that's actually what animals do.
It's a,
it's a predatory evasion crouch.
And so if they're put in a new
territory,
they'll hunker down and freeze first and
then they'll slowly unfreeze and start
to explore.
They sniff first and then they'll start
to move it.
But they do it like with trepidation and
slowly and tried to hide it.
So that's what the cat is doing and the
cat goes out into the unknown,
far enough sniffing and all of a sudden
pow.
It goes underneath the house,
just like the toddler running back to
the mother and the other,
another hippie there.
Uh,
I think that's fineas says,
where'd the cat disappeared to now?
And the fat ready character says under
the house.
And then accounts under there in the
dark with big eyes looking terrified.
Saying you'd hide too if you'd smelled
what I did.
And so what it smelled was this thing
that has like the head of a wolf and a
and a and antlers like a deer in the
tail of a skunk and the feet of a like a
chicken and horrible clause.
It's like,
well,
what is that?
Well,
it's a monstrous amalgam of that which
lurks in the unknown.
And so the cartoonists,
the comedian got it perfect,
said,
well,
what is there?
What is out in the unknown while you
need one representation,
not a thousand.
And so you take pieces of what's out
there that are relevant and you create a
single image out of that and you say,
well,
this is what's out there.
And you might say,
well no such animal as that exists,
and that's actually incorrect.
An animal,
very much animals very much like that
exists.
It's just a superordinate low resolution
category.
It includes all those weird animals that
might hurt you,
that are out in the forest.
That's a useful category,
weird animals that might hurt you.
And that's a real category.
You might say,
well,
there's differentiated things within
that category.
It's like,
yeah,
every category has that nature.
Can still be further differentiated,
maybe not protons,
you know,
they could even be differentiated with
regards to location at least.
So every category can be further
differentiated.
The question is whether the category has
some functional utility,
or at least that's one of its questions.
It's like that's the thing to be afraid
of.